>>> SO, WHERE'S THE TRIP WIRE?
M MICHAEL SMERCONISH IN
PHILADELPHIA.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE F NATO AND
THE U.S. TO ACTUALLY BE AT WAR
WITH RUSSIA?
OR ARE WE ALREADY THERE?
I ASK THE QUESTION, BECAUSE THE
HAIR-SPLITTING THAT WENT ON THIS
WEEK REGARDING POLAND'S SUPPLY
OF MIG-29 FIGHTER JETS.
POLAND SURPRISED AMERICAN
OFFICIALS BY OFFERING TO TURN
OVER ITS AGEING MIG FIGHTERS TO
UKRAINE.
BUT AMERICA BALKED WHEN POLAND
WANTED TO TRANSFER THEM THROUGH
THE U.S. AND NATO AND HAVE THEIR
FLEET REPLACED WITH
AMERICAN-MADE FIGHTER JETS AND
THE U.S. RESPONDED QUOTING IT
COULD BE EX  SS KAALA TORI.
THE BACK AND FORTH WAS A
REMINDER THAT THE JOINT EFFORT
TO PUNISH AND ULTIMATELY REPEL
RUSSIA HAS A THIRD RAIL THAT NO
ONE WANTS TO TOUCH.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID
THIS, THE BIGGER PROBLEM IS THE
MESSAGE THAT THIS FIASCO SENDS
TO MR. PUTIN ABOUT NATO BY SO
OSTENTATIOUSLY NOT SENDING THE
FIGHTERS AND SAYING THAT IS FEAR
OF ESCALATION AND TELLING THE
RUSSIAN WHAT HE DOESN'T WANT TO
WORRY ABOUT.
SAND WORLD WAR II BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES WAS BOMBED AT
PEARL HARBOR.
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER WINSTON
CHURCHILL SOUGHT TO BUY FIGHTER
PLANES FROM THE UNITED STATES.
IF DR ASKED ENGLAND TO SEND AN
AIRCRAFT CARRIER TO PICK THEM
UP.
BUT ENGLAND WAS SHORT ON
AIRCRAFT CARRIERS AND ASKED THEM
FOR THEM TO BE DELIVERED ITS
ALLY CANADA.
THE U.S. MILITARY FLYING THE
PLANES TO CANADA WOULD HAVE
BROKEN THE NEUTRALITY ACT.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THE UNITED STATES FLEW THEM TO
THE BORDER, DRAINED THEM OF FUEL
AND HORSES WERE USED TO
TRANSPORT THEM ACROSS THE BORDER
WHERE THEY WERE THEN REFUELED.
THAT MAY THEN HAVE FOLLOWED THE
LETTER OF THE LAW BUT MADE IT
CLEAR WHICH SIDE THE U.S. WOULD
BE SUPPORTING.
TWO YEARS LATER, JAPAN ENDED THE
NEUTRALITY ACT BY BOMBING PEARL
HARBOR.
AMERICAN SUPPORT HAS BEEN MORE
EXTENSIVE.
GIVING AID IN JAVELIN MISSILES
AND CONTROL BOATS.
AND ALLOCATE, ANOTHER $3.6
BILLION INCLUDING $10 BILLION OF
DIRECT OR INDIRECT MILITARY AID.
ON TOP OF THE SANCTIONS THAT
PUTIN HAS LABELED AN ECONOMIC
WAR, ACCOUNT UNITED STATES
REALLY THINK SUCH MOVES ARE
THEMSELVES NOTES  S  ESCALATING.
AND ASKED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
STEP UP ITS SUPPORT IN INCLUDING
SUPPLYING SURFACE-TO-AIR MISSILE
SYSTEMS.
40 REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
SAID PRETTY MUCH THE SAME THING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ON THIS TOPIC
SAID THIS YESTERDAY.
>> THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEND IN OFFENSIVE EQUIPMENT AND
HAVE PLANES AND TANKS AND TRAINS
GOING IN WITH AMERICAN PILOTS
AND AMERICAN PILOTS AND AMERICAN
CREWS, JUST UNDERSTAND, DON'T
KID YOURSELF, NO MATTER WHAT YOU
ALL SAY, THAT'S CALLED WORLD WAR
III.
OKAY?
>> STILL, WHY CAN THE UNITED
STATES DELIVER MILLIONS AND
BILLIONS TO BE USED FOR WEAPONS,
BUT STILL CLAIM IT'S NOT
DIRECTLY INVOLVED.
IT ALL LEADS ME TO THE SURVEY
QUESTION AT SMERCONISH.COM.
SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN AID THE
TRANSFER OF AIRCRAFT AND AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEMS TO UKRAINE?
JOINING ME IS RETIRED NAVY
ADMIRAL JAMES STAVRIDIS, HE'S
WRITTEN A WORK OF FICTION CALLED
2034, A NOVEL OF THE NEXT WORLD
WAR.
ADMIRAL, GOOD MORNING, YOU HAVE
A Ph.D. IN INTERNATIONAL LAW.
YOU WERE THE DEAN OF A GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF INTERNATIONAL LAW
DIPLOMACY.
YOU'RE THE PERFECT PERSON FOR ME
TO ASK, WHAT EXACTLY IS
PROVOCATION IN THIS CONTEXT?
>> LET'S START WITH GROUND
TROOPS WITH PUTIN IS THE ONE
PROVOKING, PUTIN IS THE
UNINVADING.
PUTIN IS THE ONE FLAGRANTLY
INVADING NATIONAL LAW.
HE'S SIMPLY INVADED.
HE'S THROWING GASOLINE OR A BON
FIRE OF WAR CRIMES BY PARADING
SYRIAN VOLUNTEERS TO THE
BATTLEFIELD.
NOW, MICHAEL, WE GOT TO START BY
SAYING THE SERIAL VIOLATOR OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW HERE IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HAVING SAID THAT, OKAY, LET'S GO
OVER TO OUR SIDE OF THE COIN
HERE WITH THE DEMOCRACY, WHAT
CAN WE DO?
I THINK THE FALSE DISCUSSION
HERE IS IT'S KIND OF AN ON AND
OFF SWITCH, IN OTHER WORDS, WE
JUST KEEP THE SWITCH OFF, AND WE
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS IN HORROR.
OR, WE FLIP THE SWITCH ON AND WE
SEND TROOPS IN.
AND WE PUT OUR JETS OS UKRAINE.
NEITHER OF THOSE ANSWERS ARE
RIGHT.
IT'S A RHEOSTAT, LIKE IN YOUR
DINING ROOM, YOU KIND OF TURN UP
THE LIGHT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN MY MIND,
WHICH IS ABOUT RIGHT.
MASSIVE ASSISTNESANCE OF MILITA
AND SUPPLYING DEFENSIVE WEAPONS.
WE'RE NOT GIVING UKRAINE
ANYTHING THEY CAN USE TO INVADE
RUSSIA.
WE'RE GIVING THEM THE SYSTEMS
THEY NEED TO ATTACK RUSSIANS WHO
ARE INVADING THEM.
I THINK WE'RE IN THE RIGHT
PLACE.
>> OKAY.
SO, IN MY HOUSE, IF IT WERE THE
THERMOSTAT, NOT THE RHEOSTAT,
I'D BE THE ONE TURNING IT ON AND
MY WIFE WOULD COME ALONG AND
COMPLETELY SHUT IT OFF.
HAS VLADIMIR PUTIN COMPLETELY
SHUT IT OFF?
IN OTHER WORDS, HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED THAT HE HAS, THROUGH
BACKCHANNEL COMMUNICATIONS
SERVED NOTICE, IF YOU TRANSFER
THOSE MIG FIGHTERS, THAT'S IT,
IT'S GAME ON WITH NATO?
>> I DOUBT IT, FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
FIRST OF ALL, HE WOULD NOT WANT
TO LAY OUT A BOLD RED LINE LIKE
THAT.
AND NOR SHOULD WE, BY THE WAY.
I THINK WE SHOULD STOP SAYING
WE'LL NEVER DO THIS, WE'LL NEVER
DO THAT.
WE SHOULD SAY THINGS LIKE AT
THIS TIME, WE'RE NOT GOING TO,
ET CETERA, POINT TWO WOULD BE
HERE HE DOESN'T WANT TO TAKE ON
A CONVENTIONAL FIGHT WITH NATO.
HE DOESN'T WANT A NUCLEAR FIGHT
EITHER.
HE'S GOT FAMILY.
HE LOVES HIS COUNTRY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO REACH FOR THE
APOCALYPSE BUTTON.
AND HE DOESN'T WANT A
CONVENTIONAL FIGHT WITH NATO
BECAUSE WE OUTNUMBER HIM.
THERE ARE SOME NOTION THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE COMPARABLE
WITH NATO FORCES.
WE OUTSPEND THEM 15 TO 1, 5 TO 1
ADVANTAGE WITH TROOPS, 5 TO 1 IN
COMBAT, YOU GET THE IDEA.
I THINK PUTIN IS RATTLING THAT
NUCLEAR SABRE HOPING WE WILL
SIMPLY BACK DOWN.
WE JUST CAN'T DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE OUR COURSE
OF ACTION.
THE ONE THING YOU MENTIONED UP
FRONT, THE MIG-29s.
I CAN SEE BOTH SIDES OF THAT
CONVERSATION.
BUT IN MY VIEW, GIVE THEM TO THE
UKRAINIANS, FIGURE OUT THE
LOGISTICS.
PUT UKRAINIAN INSIGNIA ON IT,
HAVE UKRAINIANS FLY THEM.
I THINK IT'S A HUGE MORALE BOOST
AND HAVE IMPACT ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
IT'S A HARD LOGISTICS PROBLEM
BUT WE SHOULDN'T BACK DOWN AND
BE SCARED OF OUR SHADOW IN TERMS
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> SO MY SURVEY QUESTION IS
ASKING THE VIEWERS SHOULD THE
PRESIDENT AID THE TRANSFER OF
AIRCRAFT IN UKRAINE, ADMIRAL
STAVRIDIS SAYS YES?
>> I DO.
AND I'LL MAKE A SMALL CAVEAT,
WHICH YOU DIDN'T CLARIFY IN THE
QUESTION.
I WOULD NOT PUT U.S. PILOTS
FLYING THOSE AIRCRAFT THAT YOU
REFER TO?
>> OKAY.
>> AND PART OF THE REASON THERE,
MICHAEL, NOT ONLY IT'S
INTERNATIONAL LAW, BUT IT'S ALSO
WHO'S UP THERE IN THE COCKPIT.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S NOT MADELEINE
ALBRIGHT UP THERE, FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE, KIND OF
FIGURING OUT THE BACK AND FORTH.
THAT'S GOOSE AND MAVERICK.
SAME THING ON THE RUSSIAN SIDE.
SO THE POTENTIAL FOR AN INCIDENT
BETWEEN NUCLEAR-ARMED POWERS IS
PRETTY HIGH.
>> BY THE WAY, ADMIRAL, THAT'S
IMPLIED, THAT'S IMPLIED IN MY
SURVEY QUESTION.
I DO NOT INTEND TO SUGGEST THEY
WOULD BE AMERICAN PILOTS.
>> GOTCHA.
>> HEY, YOU SPOKE TO THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY CAPABLE.
YESTERDAY, PUT THIS UP, KATHRYN,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAID THE
FOLLOWING, TWO WEEKS AFTER
RUSSIAN FORCES STREAMED INTO
NEIGHBORING UKRAINE FOLLOWING
MONTHS OF BUILDUP, EVIDENCE IS
MOUNTING THAT INVASION HAS NOT
GONE TO PLAN AND THAT RUSSIA'S
MUCH-VAUNTED MILITARY MAY NOT BE
THE FORMIDABLE FORCE ONCE
FEARED.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT RUSSIA
WILL SEIZE KYIV AND TOPPLE THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
AND IT DOESN'T MEAN CASUALTIES
AS IT CONTINUES TO DO DAILY.
BUT THE SIMPLING PACE SINCE
VLADIMIR PUTIN ORDERED LATE LAST
MONTH, AND RUSSIAN TANKS ALIKE,
HAVE RESET EXPECTATIONS FOR HOW
THE CONFLICT WILL UNFOLD.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THE RUSSIAN
CAPABILITIES THUS FAR?
>> I AM NOT SHOCKED AT THEIR
FAILURES.
I THINK THEY HAVE IMPROVED OVER
THE FORCE THAT I SURVEYSED AS TE
SUPREME ALLIED COMMANDER YEARS
AGO.
THEY STILL HAVE THREE KEY
FAULTS.
ONE ISLE THEY HAVE RESERVISTS
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING INTO THE
FIGHT.
THEY'RE INEXPERIENCED THEY'RE
AFRAID.
ALMOST DISORIENTED.
SECONDLY, LOGISTICS, THIS HAS
BEEN A SHORTFALL FOR RUSSIA,
LOGISTICS ARE HARD.
PROFESSIONALS DO LOGISTICS WELL.
WE DO THAT WELL.
RUSSIA IS FALLING WITH THAT.
AND THIRD, MICHAEL, THE GENERAL
SHIP HERE, THE ADMIRALSHIP HAS
NOT BEEN VERY GOOD.
THE BATTLE PLAN ISN'T GOOD.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION AND